وصلنا الان الى المشهد الانتخابي في تونس
حيث دخلت البلاد ومرحله الصمت الانتخابيه
قبل يوم من اقتلاع او من انطلاق عمليه
الاقتراع في الانتخابات البرلمانيه في
الداخل في هذه الاثناء يواصل الناخبون
التونسيون في المجر الادلاء باصواتهم في
الانتخابات
التشريعيه
واعلنت هيئه الانتخابات ان الانتخابات في
المجال سجلت اقبال ضعيفا في يومها الاول
وقد تجددت الدعوات لمقاطعه الانتخابات قبل
يومين من توجه الناخبين داخل البلاد الى
مراكز الاقتراع واقرر البرلمان الاوروبي
عدم ارسال بعثه لمراقبه الانتخابات
التونسيه وقال ان قراره مبني على قرار
المحكمه الافريقيه لحقوق الانسان وتقرير
لجنه البندقيه بالاضافه الى التطورات
السياسيه
والاجتماعيه في البلاد